so excited to have you guys here because
we have opened this to the community not
only to our team members but to anybody
in the community
that has not had their vaccination shot
yet that they can come in
for circa for today you have to be 21
for this event but we are also holding
an event tomorrow
for anybody that's 12 and above and it's
the pfizer shot
so the first one is today and then in
two weeks you can come back
and get your second dose we really want
to not get closed down again and we want
to remove the mass i
miss seeing people's faces we're back to
you know phase three again
and it's really important for people to
get the vaccination so that we don't get
shut down
to stop this pandemic to stop the spread
of copen19
with this new variant it's very very
contagious
and this will help stop that so for us
it's important when you come in
you don't have to wear a mask all the
time we don't have to wipe things down
it's an inconvenience to not only you
i've done it you've done it you walk
halfway to your car or halfway away from
your car and you're like oh my god i
forgot your mask so that's also an
inconvenience
and we want everybody to feel safe